it's been over a year since i last did a
video in the differential equations
playlist and i thought i would start
picking up making a couple of videos and
i think where i left off i said that i
would do a
non-homogeneous linear equation using
the laplace transform so let's do one as
a bit of a warm-up now that we've had a
or at least i've had a one-year hiatus
maybe you're watching these continuously
so you're probably more warmed up than i
am
so if we have the equation
the second derivative of y plus y is
equal to
sine
of 2 t
and we're given some initial conditions
here the initial conditions are y of 0
is equal to 2
and y prime
of 0
is equal to 1. and where we left off and
you probably remember this you've
probably recently watched the last video
to solve these we just take the laplace
transforms of all the sides we solve for
the
laplace transform of the of the function
and then we take the inverse laplace
transform if that doesn't make sense
then let's just let's just do it in this
video and hopefully the example will
clarify all confusion
so in the last videos either the last
one of the previous one i showed you
that the laplace transform
the laplace transform of the second
derivative of y
is equal to s squared times the laplace
transform
of y
and we keep lowering the degree on s so
minus s
times y of zero you can kind of think of
it as taking the derivative this is an
integral it's not exactly the
anti-derivative of this but the laplace
transform it is an integral the
transform is an n integral so y of zero
is kind of a you know one derivative uh
away from that and then minus
y prime
of zero and then we could also rewrite
this and this is just a purely
notational issue i could write this
instead of you know instead of writing
laplace transform of y all the time i
could write this as s squared times
capital y
of s because this is going to be a
function of s not a function of y minus
s
times y of 0
minus y prime y of 0. these are going to
be numbers right these aren't functions
these are the the function evaluated at
0 or the function evaluated or the
derivative of the function evaluated at
0 and we know what these values are
y of 0
right here is 2 and y prime of 0
is 1. it was given to us so if we take
the laplace transforms of both sides of
this equation first we're going to take
the laplace transform of this term right
there which we've really just done the
laplace transform of the second
derivative
is
s squared
times laplace transform
of the function which we write as
capital y of s
minus
this minus 2s they gave us that initial
condition
minus 2s
and then minus 1
right this term right here is just 1. so
minus 1. so that's term right there we
then we want to take the laplace
transform of y by itself
so this is just plus
y of s
right the laplace transform of y so i'll
just rewrite the laplace transform
of y i'm just rewriting it in this
notation
y of s it's good to get used to either
one and then we want to take this is
going to be equal to the laplace
transform of sine
of 2t and we i showed you in a video
last year of what we showed what the
laplace transform of sine of a t is but
i'll write it down here just so you
remember it
laplace transform
of the sine
of a t
is equal to
a
over s squared
plus
a squared
right a over s squared plus a squared so
the laplace transform
of sine of two t
here a is two this is going to be two
over s squared plus four so if we take
the laplace transform of both sides of
this the right hand side is going to be
two
over
s squared
plus 4.
now what we can do is we can separate
out all the y of s terms
and so we can
factor well i guess we could say factor
out their coefficients so that's a y of
s term that's a y of s term
and so we can write the left-hand side
here as
s squared
that's that term
plus one the coefficient on that term
s squared plus one
times y of s
let me do it in green
so this is a y of s and this is y of s
times
y of s
and then we have the non-y of s terms
these two right here so minus 2s minus 1
is equal to 2 over s squared plus 4. we
can add 2s plus 1 to both sides to
essentially move this to the right hand
side and we're left with
we are left with
s squared plus 1. times y of s
times y of s
is equal to
two
over s squared plus four
plus two s
plus one
now we can divide both sides of this
equation by s squared plus one
and we get the laplace transform of y y
of s
is equal to
two let me switch colors it's equal to 2
over s squared plus 4
times this thing right here i'm dividing
the whole both sides of this equation by
this term right there so times
s squared plus 1. it's in the
denominator so i'm dividing by it
plus
2s
plus 1 i have to divide both of those
terms by the s squared plus 1
divided by s squared plus 1
divided by
s squared plus 1.
now in order to be able to take the
inverse laplace transform of this i need
to get it in some type of
simple fraction form these are actually
easier to do but this one's a little bit
difficult i want to do some partial
fraction decomposition to break this up
into maybe simpler fractions and since
both of these so what i want to do i'm
going to do a little bit of an aside
here and this really is the hardest part
of these problems is to is the algebra
breaking this thing up so since we're
going to break this up i'm going to
break this up so let me write this this
way 2
over s squared plus 4
times s squared plus 1. i'm going to
break this up into two fractions this is
the partial fraction decomposition
one fraction is s squared plus four and
the other fraction is s squared
plus one and since both of these
both of these denominators have
of degree two the numerators are going
to have they're going to be of degree
one so they're going to be sum let me
write it this way a this one will be a s
plus b
and then this one will be c s plus d um
this is just pure algebra here this is
just partial fraction decomposition i've
made a couple of videos on it
and i'm saying that i'm assuming that
this expression right here can be broken
up into two expressions of this form and
now i need to solve for a b
c and d so let's see how we can do that
so if we were to if i were to start with
these two and add them up what do i get
i would have to multiply these times so
my denominator my common denominator
would be this thing again
it would be
s squared plus four
times
s squared
plus
one
and now i'm gonna have to multiply the a
s plus b
a s
plus b
times this s squared plus 1
times s squared plus 1. this as it's
right now if these two terms would
cancel out you'll just get this term but
i need to add it to this right here
so you get plus
cs plus d
times this term right here
times
s squared
plus
four and now let's see what we could do
to match up the terms here with this
number 2 right here so let's multiply
all of this out so a s times s squared
a s times s squared is a
s
to the third a s times one is plus a s
b times s squared so plus b
s squared
and then you have b times one is plus
b
and then you have c s times s squared
that's cs to the third
c
s to the third
and then cs times four
so it's plus four
cs
and then let's see these are these are
these these problems are tiring okay and
and and i also have a cold so this is
especially tiring but i'll soldier
forward where was i so i've multiplied
the c's times each of these i have to
multiply the d so plus
d s squared that's d times that one
plus d times four so plus four
d so that's all of them and i just wrote
it this way so i have the the common
degree terms under each other so if i
were to add the entire numerator
i get
and i'll just switch colors
somewhat arbitrarily i get
a plus c
times s to the third
plus let me write the s squared term
next plus b plus d times s squared and
i'll write this s term
plus
a plus four c times s
plus b
plus four d
this is just the numerator this is when
i just added these two things up this
whole thing
up here
simplifies to this i don't know if the
word simplifies is appropriate but it
becomes this expression right here and
that's just the numerator the
denominator is still what we had written
before the denominator is still the s
squared plus 4
times the s squared plus 1.
of course i have to show that this is a
fraction
and this is going to be equal to this
thing over here 2
over
s squared plus 4
times s squared plus 1.
now what why did i go through this this
whole mess right here well the reason
why i went through it is because we
should be able to solve for a b c and d
so let's see
a plus c this is the coefficient on the
s cubed term do we see any s cubed terms
here no we see no s cubed terms here so
a plus c let me write this down
a plus c must be equal to zero because
we see nothing here that has an s to the
third
b plus d is a coefficient on the s
squared term do we see any s squared
terms here no so b plus d must be equal
to zero b plus d is equal to zero
a plus four c
a plus four c are there's are are the
coefficients on the s term i see no s
term over here so a plus four c
a plus 4c
must also
be equal to
0.
and then finally
finally we look at just the constant
terms and we do have a constant term on
the left hand side of this equation we
have to so b plus 4d didn't want to make
it that thick
b plus 4d
must be equal to
must be equal to 2. so let's see if we
can do any so this seems like these
linear equations are pretty easy to
solve for let's subtract
let's subtract this
from this
so a or let me subtract the bottom one
from the top one so a minus a that's
zero a
and then c minus four c
minus three c is equal to zero and so
you get c is equal to zero if c is equal
to zero a plus c is equal to zero a must
be equal a must be equal to 0. let's do
the same thing here let's subtract this
from that
so you get b minus b is 0
and then minus 3 d that's just d minus 4
d and then 0 minus 2 is equal to -2 and
then you get d
is equal to
d
what do we get d is equal to
two-thirds
d is equal to two-thirds right minus two
divided by minus three is two-thirds and
then
this this isn't a minus here i wrote
that there later we said b plus d is
equal to zero so b must be the opposite
of d right we could write b is equal to
minus d
or
b is equal to minus two-thirds
let's remember all of this
and go back to our original problem
because we we've kind of so actually let
me just be clear so we can rewrite two
over
s squared plus four times s squared
plus one we can rewrite this as well a
is zero b is minus two thirds so this is
equal to minus two-thirds
over
s squared plus four
and then c is zero we figured that out
and then d is two-thirds so plus
two-thirds
over
s squared
plus one so all of that work that i just
did
that was just to break up this piece
right here that was just to break up
that piece right then of course we have
these other two pieces here that we
can't forget about so all after all of
this work what do we have and i'm going
to make sure i don't make a careless
mistake here
we get
we get our the laplace transform
of y's you can see the algebra is the
hardest part here
is equal to
this first term
i'm just going back this first term
which i've now decomposed
into this
into this so it's
minus let me write it this way minus
1 3 and i think you're going to see in a
second why i'm writing this way minus 1
times
over
s squared
plus 4
and then
plus two thirds
plus two thirds times
one over s squared plus one and you're
probably saying so why are you writing
it this way well you can already
immediately see that this is going to be
this is the laplace transform of sine of
2t this is a laplace transform of sine
of t so i wanted to write this 2 here
because this is 2 this is 2 squared this
is 1 this is 1 squared so i wanted to
write it in this form this was just the
first term we had two more terms to
worry about
we don't want to make a careless mistake
i have 2s over s squared plus 1. so let
me write that down
so plus
plus 2
times 2 times s over s squared
plus one
plus
last one
plus one over s squared plus one
plus one
over s squared
now we just take the inverse laplace
transform of the whole thing and then
we'll know what a y is
let me just write
so you know just just as a just to
remember the laplace transform so this
is going to be a little inverse is going
to be sine of 2t let me just write just
so we have it here so you know i'm not
doing some type of voodoo the laplace
transform of sine of a t
is equal to a over s squared plus a
squared and the laplace transform
of cosine
of a t
is equal to s
over s squared plus a squared let's just
remember those two things when we take
the inverse laplace transform of both
sides of this equation
the inverse laplace transform of the
laplace transform of y well that's just
y
this y maybe we'll write as a function
of t
is equal to
well this is the laplace transform of
sine of 2t you can just do some pattern
matching right here right if a is equal
to 2 then this would be laplace
transform of sine of 2t so it's minus
1 3 times sine
of two t
plus
two thirds
times this is a laplace transform of
sine of t if you just make a is equal to
one sine of t is laplace transform is
one over s squared plus one so plus
two-thirds times the sine
of t
and let me do the next one in blue just
because it was already written in blue
plus
two times this is a laplace transform of
cosine of t if you make a is equal to
one
then the cosine t laplace transform is s
over s squared plus one so two times
cosine
of t
and then one last term plus
this is just like this one over here
this is just a laplace transform of sine
of t
plus sine
of t and we're almost done we're
essentially done but there's a little
bit more simplification we can do
i have two thirds times the sine of t
here and then i have another one sine of
t here so i can add the two-thirds to
the one
right what's two-thirds plus one or
three-thirds it's five-thirds so i can
write y of t is equal to minus one-third
sine
of two t
plus these two terms i'm just going to
add up plus five thirds
sine
of t and then i have this last term here
plus
two
cosine of t
so this was a hairy problem a lot of
work and we saw the hardest part really
was just the partial fraction
decomposition that we did up here not
making any careless mistakes but at the
end we got a pretty neat answer that's
not too complicated that satisfies
this non-homogeneous
non-homogeneous
differential equation we we were able to
incorporate the boundary conditions as
we did it anyway hopefully you found
that
vaguely vaguely satisfying it was a good
warm up after a year of no differential
equations